yeah he's great yeah and I was talking
with a guy who knows UFC better than
most and uh I go I can't wait for Hamza
Polo class to goes dude I think Costa
starches something like what what yeah I
think I think your hometop mops the
floor of them I don't think he's
competitive and then everyone will go
back and like yeah well if he fights the
same we fight about against Gilbert
burns like here's the thing worst fight
of his life he decided just to stand Toe
to Toe with Gilbert Burns exchanged
shots fought like a dumb early in his
career you know in the UFC still won
though like that's what you're gonna
that's where you're gonna harp on
the guy learned from it look what he
does like Kevin Holland that's the thing
it's not like deal with some punk like
dude what Gilbert's a Savage he went
toe-to-toe and just stood in the pocket
and still beat him dude
so I just I don't know what podcast is
gonna do could be wrong it's MMA could
be wrong